i come to this talk passionate about
this sentence
why is common sense been eliminated from
our industry
[Applause]
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
gary thank you for joining us thanks for
having me matt how are you
i'm doing well good so uh
i'm going to pontificate here for like
10 or 15 minutes but
what i really really want to do knowing
the incredible pedigree of the audience
and many
if not most of you could equally and
should be up here speaking
i i really am passionate about q a and
getting into the details because i'm
gonna go macro here
which is what you have to do when you
don't have the context of where
everyone's angle is from sales to
marketing
the incredible agency partners here are
thinking about one thing the brand teams
are thinking about a different thing the
media team is thinking about another
thing
the talent that has been so incredible
uh
in the content is thinking about another
thing but we're all bound by the same
thing which is attention creativity
business results uh altruistic impact on
society
and so please please please as i set
this framework of how i see the world
and what i'm seeing
please jump in and and start firing away
with however matt taught you
questions or asked because i really want
to get into details because i think
you know for me i i love barbells
you know i love the macro psychology and
what's actually happening the strategy
but i'm also extremely practical i think
one of the things that's been very hard
for me
in being in madison avenue is the
creative industry
i think a lot of times struggles with
create
with with practicality a lot of times
it's about the creative and i i think a
lot about the attention
and the business and then the creative i
call my abc's
and i think a lot of times it's creative
creative creative and there's a tone def
definitely to business
sometimes the media plan on the
attention side is integrated with the
creative but they're siloed
and in that siloed in the in the middle
the bee is
is kind of left to struggle and that's
why the sales teams and
and retail incentive programs and all
those things
have emerged in leverage because i think
of the lack of practicality of
advertising
over the last 50 years but i think a
good place to go
is actually the topic of the moment if
you're watching what's going on with amc
and gamestop um you're seeing one of the
most powerful institutions
uh over the last 100 years in commerce
be put to its knees
wall street right you're seeing hedge
funds which have completely dominated
the ecosystem
uh lose five billion dollars in a week
because a bunch of humans got together
and um and made a decision and there's
really nothing stopping that
you can shut down a discord talking
about wall street but
you're going to have to regulate the
internet to actually stop what's
happening right now
because you can go into a forum where
you can go to a facebook group
like what what are you going to do are
you going to just put every human jail
like you know what are we talking about
going back to communism
you know so i think that uh we're living
an incredible time and i think for
everybody here
it's incredibly important to understand
why that matters to us as communicators
marketers business people we talk a lot
about owning our brand
controlling the narrative we spend
ungodly amounts of time
in boardrooms making subjective
decisions and no matter how incredible
the talent is
ricardo monica marcel pedro i think
about all the great people i've worked
with through the years
lucas no matter how great the talent is
miguel
of making the subjective call on the
creative
this false narrative that we believe
that we control the brand positioning
that we that we're gonna tell the story
that we're gonna dictate it is laughable
go
right now and i mean it like literally
where's mine
go right now to your phone go into
instagram
i'm gonna do it myself and literally put
in bud light
like search it i'm searching right now
on the spot
bud light in real time tags
all right 1.8 million posts here we go
here it is
all this creative has a hell of a lot
more consumption than what bud light
does on its social media channels by
itself
so this narrative of spending 800 hours
of global
stella and local stella debating what
gets posted on instagram
when there's 800 posts that were posted
for people to see
and decide what they think of the brand
being done while we were in boardrooms
debating one post
and i just see matt smiling this is real
talk my friends listen this is real talk
i'm quite busy you are a great partner
but i come to this talk
passionate about creative
passionate about business but most of
all
passionate about this sentence why is
common sense
been eliminated from our industry like
why can't like in 38 seconds
i just described very logically
and in real life why abi globally will
waste
40 000 hours debating creative on social
media platforms whether draftline does
it or vayner or leo burnett or global
and
do you know the global and local
dynamics that happen in this company
the politics are unbearable on a good
day
and i feel bad for the individuals we
need a strategy shift
right it's always going to come down to
the work i think megan's speaking here
who i'm obsessed with
you know that work that we did together
you know
at with vayner and the budweiser team
that work matters right that work really
matters what we did with
nwsl but but how do you get there
it's by listening it's by being common
sense oriented
the women's national team is like the
like literally like the feeling i just
felt of warmth is incredible
it doesn't make sense that we only care
for two weeks every four years
of course we should care about this
right of course we should keep playing
like
of course it should have attention but
where does that come from that comes
from listening when you do social
properly what what an incredible
situation that's brewing social media
content is where brand is actually being
built
it just is and and it's time that we
finally accept it
like brand is being built in the lower
and middle funnel
there's far more consumption of ultra
and stella
and budweiser happening on this phone
today then on a tvc
outside a super bowl which ironically
some brands are
and aren't doing this year and i think
the work that budweiser is doing is very
strategic because
we've done it for so long but
we need to have a new conversation my
friends please let what you see going on
with bitcoin and sports cards
and wall street and discord and
clubhouse like
isn't everybody here tired of just being
slow and
culturally relevant like isn't it just
time for us to like isn't that what this
meeting's about
right isn't this meeting about let's
take a step out because i do it too
i'm not sitting on a high horse i get
into my minutia too but
these meetings correct me if i'm wrong
later when matt jumps in matt
these are times to step back and think
we're taking time out from working right
now to consume
i think it's time we understand what's
actually happening why gamestop can go
from almost going out of business to 300
a share people the internet
the pipes of the internet rule the day
has the social discourse in america and
around the world
not taught you what's going on
distribution has been disrupted my
friends
we can't run the same media playbook and
when you don't run the same media
playbook
it changes the entire creative playbook
we have to score differently we have to
act differently
please it's just it's over
don draper is [ __ ] dead he's really
dead
like not even kind of dead and and we
need to understand that and the second
we do as an organization
incredible things happen the politics
between global and local
change because we become and stick with
me here this is the
word of the day this is an and game
creatively not an ore game this you know
stella can be both super premium
and affordable luxury funny and
serious it should be relevant to as many
people as
who does does anybody here not want
everybody to drink everything
that we sell like because
we decided in a board room who should
buy stella versus bud light that's how
we should communicate they should both
communicate to everybody they're monster
brands
we are making enormous common sense
mistakes in the ecosystem we completely
have lost our way
with where brand is being built and we
have to get back to the abc's it starts
with attention
business is the punch line then
we can talk about creativity fitting
into a and b let's get our abcs down
this is simple this is common sense but
corporate america the global corporate
world
and madison avenue are not living in it
they're just not and so
you know i view our entire space the way
i view
nissan versus tesla the way i view
abc network versus netflix
the way i view amazon selling toys
versus toys r us
it's changed the way i view influencers
over famous people this company is going
to be thrilled to sign seven-figure
deals
with famous people while there's
influencers that are ten times more
famous
with our target audience that we could
get for hundreds if not tens of
thousands of dollars
we just need more cultural relevance we
need more speed we need more empathy not
apathy
we need to be more consumer-centric we
need to be faster culturally relevant we
need to change our processes
the way we judge we have to we have to
suffocate our own
[ __ ] within ourselves it is it's
time
it's 20 21 it's time
thank you
thank you wow don draper is dead all
right i have some my own questions
first of all i'm going to address the
questions you had for me please
look like and you've worked with us long
enough we're all about learning
and that's what this day is about and we
could have filled this with people only
from anheuser-busch or abi
or other fortune 500 companies and we
did not that's why you see the lineup
that you do
um so we appreciate the perspective but
that's what this is all about
um i just want you know look the first
question i have is i hear you
you know budweiser and stella should be
marketing to everybody but how do you
reconcile that with brand positioning
and differentiation in the market
um i think it comes down to being
culturally and contextually relevant to
far more individual groups the way you
break through
is you have everybody like you not
you've decided you're going after
coastal white males
and then spend all your money going
after that that it just actually doesn't
make sense
it made sense when the cost of
television distribution
and the cost of television creative was
expensive and that was your at-bat
and you had to go a certain route but
with the internet where we can go
consumer-centric up
and and really be relevant to so many
more people
i think i i can't believe how much i
still see
people talk about reach and awareness
when they talk about some of the biggest
beverage brands
in the history of mankind like
budweiser does not have an awareness
problem
neither does nicolo vulture for that
matter this is about
really understanding how to create
relevance
through contextual creative to how it's
being distributed
the separation of media and creative mat
destroyed
the value of agencies to brands in my
opinion i really believe that
because it made it hard for people to be
accountable i have empathy
for the people that are on here that are
just in creative when they just control
that part and they have to hand it to a
media planner company that's separate
from them even if it's in the same
holding company
they've got different bonuses different
cultures it's different
it's really hurt us and i think the
internet requires it
and so i think we'll see in the next
decade it all go back back together
but i think this to answer the question
it's how do you get
seven meaningful groups of individuals
a million people in each two million
people in each four million people in
each
because you were so contextual to them
monica
is one of the great things in our
partnership her incredible push around
localization let's do big boy in atlanta
let's do this in utah
it works why because people in atlanta
like
outkast go figure like it's not
complicated
and we go way too much vanilla push down
instead of basking robins
up and so the way i see it is because i
do believe that brand is being built in
the digital platforms
how do we have seven to twelve
meaningful groups of
consumer bases how do we then make very
sharp with teeth in it creative for
those groups
which then creates consideration and and
and connection
so i want to follow that up because as
you know you mentioned megan repino's
about to join us and i think this could
be it but give us an example that you
did
with ab that that shows this type of
thinking
this type of creativity i'm obsessed
with the work that we do with megan and
obsessed with the work that we did with
dwyane wade
right those are monsters but i'm i kind
of
you know subconsciously already went
there the localization work that
budweiser is doing
with monica and marcel is something that
i
on the record is going to be replicated
across abi
globally in five years because it will
be proven to be historically true which
is
contextual creative at scale 68 of those
executions for the price of one hardcore
tvc
you know if i'm launching bud light
seltzer all over again
i'm doing 113 atlanta big boy
budweisers not tv buy
grp just get everybody to be aware
because i can do it at six i can do it
113 times
and meaningfully to get the same overall
awareness
i believe to be frank even more because
of the way grp's are scored
and how quickly television viewership is
vanishing
especially in commercial form now you've
got incredible creative
i mean api has anomaly wide
incredible firepower giving those
individuals
much more creative room than fit this in
a 30-second film
yeah so that is by far my favorite work
matt
i want to follow up with a question i
think it was a good segue but then
look i know you're a creative team well
shout out to nick
but what are the principles of
creativity that won't ever change
but what are the new rules that
companies and agencies and brands need
to be adopting
creative is the variable of success you
know when i do these things when i go to
can when i
a a like a lot of creatives get upset
with me
i read the comments and i'm like no no
no no i gotta
and i put on myself not on them i'm like
i gotta do a better job communicating
this
like i think i'm liberating creativity
i cannot believe that creative humans
think a 30-second video
and then matching luggage to the
tagline and video in digital banner form
is considered creative in 2021 matt
i think this is you know so what is true
a good story
something that makes somebody cry smile
think
is always gonna win the new rules are
how do you stop someone that's going
like this
do you actually even understand the
creative platforms and the nuances do
you know what an instagram
you know reel is versus a story do you
understand how carousels work
do you understand how to start a
conversation about
craft beer on clubhouse which becomes an
awareness play do you
understand pre-roll spotify you know
audio buying do you understand
influencers mid-tail long tail do you
understand two minute 37 second videos
outperform
outperform business 30 second videos
even though facebook and google and
twitter will tell you make shorter
videos
on their best practices because it works
for their metrics but not for business
results
because if you make a great two minute
37 second video that everybody watches
they're gonna buy your stuff you know so
i think
the the rule is a great story is a great
story the right tagline the right
emotion the right moment
you can watch all nine or whatever
seasons of mad men it's all there
it's all right that's all right the
problem is you used to have people
watching them
so distribution matters and you have way
more flexibility now
in the new game to do very different
stuff and that matters
so i don't know if you want to bring
that home we have a question that's on
that note from katie
ostrecco thanks katie what is the
biggest mistake the biggest mistake
you see brands make when they shift from
traditional to digital strategies
a complete lack of understanding of
context
creative and how to really spend media
because most go to digital and they just
replicate tv
dna they go for mass scale so they buy
you know a three million dollar facebook
ad 21 to 35
hit enter against one piece of creative
and they're like why is this not working
because you're not actually using the
tool properly it's like taking a
screwdriver
and trying to hammer in a picture on
your wall use the tools properly there's
a
stunning misunderstanding mat of how to
use these tools gym shark
does 500 million dollars in revenue
on instagram like
you know wish the shopping app does
eight billion on the back of facebook
like these numbers are real now you know
bang energy drink
right like this is real now like i don't
understand what people are talking about
like
liquid iv i was involved with right all
the brand is being
like but when you go from traditional to
digital
you've had a entire ecosystem of
traditionalists
taking the same blueprint strategy and
deploying it to digital
which has been a massive mistake which
is why digital doesn't work
nothing works if you don't know how to
use it a basketball works for lebron
matt
he's gonna make billions because of it a
basketball doesn't work for me i've torn
both my meniscuses
right but but a cell phone and social
networks have worked for me
and they haven't worked for an a-list
actor when i started 15 years ago
because now she or he's irrelevant
because they were too snotty
to play on this so tools only work if
you know how to use it
most agencies and brands
are not using digital properly they go
programmatic
because they're going for lowest cost
there's no conversation of creative and
media together
properly volume of creative
finding right versus pushing down and
having audacity of right
there's a lot going on here brother
haley caldwell asked
what do you think about the thought that
if you were targeting to everyone then
you were targeting to no one
one more time i apologize what do you
think about the thought that if you were
targeting to everyone then you were
targeting to no one
um i think it's a
really really really interesting point
here's the difference
i think that that's actually what's
happening with
you know with creative today i would
argue what she said is right
because when you're talking once and
you're trying to talk to everybody
inherently you can only be relevant
to a small percentage of the people that
you paid to get in front of
when you go with the volume model up
against a bunch of cohorts
you're actually talking to 12 different
people for example matt
and haley i i've let's use you matt
because we can go back and forth
there's seven different mats there's
matt that abi knows
then there's matt in his personal
relationships
then there's the mat with his single
best friend crew whether that was high
school college right
yeah they're watching right then there's
and they're all different and the and in
those bubbles you talk differently
you actually talk differently different
slang different stories
so i think the i actually think the
statement and the question's right
i think television commercial like
modern what's considered today branding
is trying to talk to everybody thus
talking to nobody
i think what i'm talking about is 25
megan
videos 67 dwayne wade videos and as you
can imagine
that megan video is gonna speak to a
whole lot of women
you know across the spectrum of women
and a whole lot of
compassionate men and a whole lot of
americans who are like yeah we do love
these girls only once
like that's crazy that's [ __ ] like
and so that's one group guess what the
dwyane wade video
talked to a whole nother group guess
what the the
big boy play for those atlanta people
that talk to another group so
i think i'm trying to talk to everybody
but talk to them in context the way matt
talks to his buddies on a four-day
weekend in vegas
on a reunion versus when he comes back
into the office monday and there's a
real different mat
in that board room and that's exactly
right it's human
it's right it's not if matt was talking
the same way everywhere he'd be fired
right he'd probably have you know so
he'd be super cool with his boys but
everything else would burn down to the
ground or if he talked the same way to
everybody
he'd have a great career but his boys
would have dropped him a long time ago
because they don't care about his
powerpoint presentation
right so that's context is the game
pete asks we already know about tick
tock what is an untapped platform for
brands
i think clubhouse tick tock and linkedin
are the three brands that i would play
on
for example stella should get very
serious about linkedin those are all
three platforms that have gross
i mean slang term for awesome incredible
growth organic reach you can make one
post and
take talks about becoming age verified
for alcohol so
i'm i'm hopeful and i'll be a voice at
the table of pushing this org there very
quickly um
linkedin's organic reach is unbelievable
i would also argue that there are
specific execution face instagram reels
not igtv not regular in feed post a huge
play for the brands here
um mid-tier influencers
starting our own podcast i think ultra
should have three podcasts that talk
about extreme
you know sports and escapism and
basketball so becoming a little bit more
of a
much like draftline is building a
creative infrastructure internally
a publishing infrastructure internally
is another
untapped arena um i think
every single person that crafts a beer
in
our ecosystem should be hosting a
saturday and friday night
beer talk on clubhouse let's get every
charismatic
you know brewmaster and that's probably
25 to 40
of them because some are introverted and
don't want to do it and let's get them
in there
let's record it because that feature is
now coming and you can do it if you just
tell people you're doing it
let's make content out of it there's a
lot of contemporary work math that can
be done
um i don't want you to give a an a b
well you can maybe an a b example if you
want but non a b
which brand campaign from 2020 really
hit the mark
i have no idea and let me tell you why
when i look at and i do it rarely but
when i look at the ad ages or the ad
weeks or the things that the industry
does
i always do the same thing is the
business up
you know why am i keep going down to big
boy versus let's say dwyane wade
i like business results so
you know right chipotle might have done
something cool and we
we all love the nike commercial it's a
beautiful piece of craft
did that move the model did that move
the business
i think brand always does but was nike
already there
like how many more did it change
people's opinion
you know so to me i i never
ever have a good answer for this mat
because there's a
my subjective opinions if something was
funny clever
good craftsmanship yeah that to me is a
focus group of one and that's hypocrisy
that's not interesting
b i really think that we're
listen we're not talking about raising
funds for a non-profit or getting
somebody voted
for we're sitting here and talking about
business every one of us right now
so to me the purpose of marketing and
branding is to drive business results
and so the ones that won are the ones
that
um actually impacted the business
i like this question from ali burton
allie thanks for the question
gary hi how do you think attention will
shift five years
from now what should we be doing to get
ahead of that
ali i'm not sure right because i you
know even though i've been yelling for a
long time about voice
so in some way i did feel like i saw
clubhouse coming-ish
um uh you really don't know
i'm not [ __ ] um it's not fun for me to
think i
am nostradamus or i've had an incredibly
good career of investing early about
bitcoin in 2014
all my social stuff but i don't think
i'm talented in predicting anything i
think what i'm very good at
is adjusting to reality you know
i think there's coaches that do a great
job game planning
and then they come to the game i'm a
different kind of coach
i game plan but i'm not like up to three
o'clock in the morning bleeding until
the game
what i'm incredible at is watching the
first half my team's down 21 to six but
i've
watched the first half we go into
halftime i only got 15 minutes
my adjustments are gnarly like i think
we go back out there and we win 28 to
24. and and so that's my answer i
i i don't think anybody can actually
predict i think ar
vr audio all have incredible
upside do i think that alexa send me a
case of beer is going to be real life i
do
do i think that this company should
figure out when they say beer that it's
us
not our competitors i do you know do i
think that vr
is coming and i see tens of thousand
people paying for subscriptions to wear
their glasses and do things i do
do i think it'd be cool if we did beer
tastings that way around the world
beers around the world through vr in 17
years 13 years i do
but i don't know if it's 17 13 two
minutes you know like that kind of stuff
um so i think that to me it's more about
keeping your ear to the ground every
second whether that's knowing that
the baby and meg the stallion and
charlie demilio are about to pop or that
clubhouse
and and and bitcoin are about to pop or
sports cards
or if it means that you know a new
platform that's just
launched today has a shot um that's what
i do i
listen daily and day trade attention
more than plan it
i gotta get this in matthew bull just
wrote as a jets fan you must be used to
your team being down at halftime thank
you matthew
we'll see you later and then
real um real quick and i'll get to it
matthew the reason i'm so excited is my
new head coach has the same haircut as
you my friend
and that because i admire you so much i
think that that is going to work out
nicely and you know
i'm matthew bulls here one of my true
favorite all-time
creatives matthew's career is built on
unbelievable creative ideation i
believe what i'm about to say i believe
if 24 year old matthew was coming into
this world
he would have had a 40-time bigger
career because matthew coming up his
game
had to be reliant on somebody else's
subjective opinion
i am predicting that matthew's 30 best
ideas never saw the day of light
and if people listened to me in the
first 15 minutes here they would
understand what it means is
matthew's ideas will come and see the
day of life
and to me that is game changing and so
his incredible hall of fame career as
matthew has had
i think he left some of his trophies on
the field and i hope that the next
matthews and even matthew because he's
still a young man
like if we understand that up in that
way
there's going to be much better ideas to
see the world nonetheless i know you
want to get one more in before we get
out of here
yeah uh i'm going to try to get two more
in um
my friend laura krug from the stella
team gary
reflecting inward what do you think is
the best work vayner
your team did this year and why what
were you disappointed about or wish was
done different
and why that's really really good
i my team did a very bad job in 2020
of finishing off the fight
we come in with very strong points of
view
and then we allow our clients to get us
to a much
safer boring corporate place
based on politics and subjectivity and
our account team
creatives and strategists have been
hearing from me this year of like listen
we get paid to think
we have the right thinking i really know
we do because i'm looking at everything
outside of madison avenue
don't fold like a cheap chair when you
get pushed back on so
very disappointed how often we were
willing to go back
three steps which then took the juice
out of
an a execution and made it a b minus or
c plus
which then just doesn't hit the radar
our best work
scott's i think scott you know i don't
know if some of you saw this but scott's
just awarded vayner
its entire full funnel creative and
media 1960 leo burnett
full media aor full creative not just
social not just digital
above the line the whole throttle why we
were able to get in there in the digital
way and
and the abi team knows i want and pedro
if he's listening knows i want
vayner to do creative and media together
in social so that we can do what we're
scott's png pepsi they're all going in
the same direction
because we have both together we're able
to show brand building
and sales results and but scott's was
just insane what we were able to do
october to february before kovid changed
their culture
drove business in off season and more
importantly had them credibly prepared
for covid which was a natural spike of
their business with backyards
all of which has led to them doing their
first super bowl spot this year
that you all see and i hope you enjoy it
and wait til you see the wrinkle we put
in there
another 2021 example i can't wait to get
your feedback
look i think i think we're up to
something i really do and and i'm really
proud of that work and
and it led to a relationship that is
extremely unusual
in uh in today's modern world all right
i'm gonna have one more question from
the chat i'm gonna end with a question
for me
this uh one comes from shelby you
mentioned internet regulation do you
feel like this is finally coming
it's been a conversation for over 15
years but now that is infiltrating the
stock market do you think the movement
will gain momentum i do and i think it's
gonna be sad
because i think let me rephrase i don't
think it's gonna be sad
i think it has momentum i think it's
i think there's so much good from it
that people don't understand
and that regula and that we're not
focusing on right now
so much happiness so much escapism so
much ben
best friendship we're so focused on the
negativity and now the disruption
that i think that's the one-two punch
that may get us there
i think it would i think it's i think
it's a scary slope
regulated internet
i just want to remind everybody
regulated internet is fine and dandy
when the people in control see the world
the way you do
it's not as interesting when they don't
and so
there's a reason that iran russia and
china are the company's
company funny the countries that have
regulated internet there's a reason
just want to remind everybody if we
believe in freedom
this is real freedom it's just real
freedom changes the rules just like
america was built on from
london rule it's going to be a very
philosophical thing but i do think it's
gaining momentum which is too bad
because i think it's going to have a lot
more
secondary collateral negatives than
people are anticipating right now they
just don't like
the negativity and they don't like the
unstableness
but sometimes that's the best thing
because it's leading you to your next
place
and your question matt last question
today's all about creativity
celebrating it whether it's somebody
starting out in their career
or somebody who's been at it for 20
years what advice do you have
on gaining inspiration and staying ahead
and and sort of having a force of
creativity in the work you do
fight for yes and and fight for yes
and and demonize no and or
and watch your creative world change
upside down
i'm back to the people like matthew and
others
i've been in the wine business i've been
in silicon valley
it's unbelievable how much i love the
humans in this industry
when i go to one of the reasons i miss
can is like
we may compete in the micro micro micro
with an anomaly or a wide an or
a media com or a droga but like
or you know a mind share but in real
life this is all the humans are just
incredible
right and i know i'm a lightning rod to
some and i'll get the hisses and what
have you but when i sit down and have a
glass of rose
some of the nicest wonderful best people
i love
have come are in this industry on the
flip side and remember what i'm about to
say
i was in the wine business and silicon
valley
this industry has a lot of undertone
resentment
and negative things and i think the
reason it does is the business is built
on
or and no
and i think the freedom creatively of
understanding what i'm saying about
brand building in the mid and lower
funnel
where everything's a yes and
is liberating to the artists that are
incredible in this industry
and i wish more people understood it i
think um i think history will look at me
as a great champion of creativity
even though i care about business
results i care about the craft
i just care about ideas the most and i
know that people
consider quality in many different ways
it doesn't need a red camera
sometimes it's the cleverness of the
wordsmithing sometimes it's knowing how
to use an animated gif or an emoji at
the right moment
and i just wish people got that because
when you go to yes and
when you understand brand is built in
the lower and middle funnel
in 2021 you can make 87 commercials
instead of one
and you can actually tell the full story
instead of having to chop it to 30
because you know in your hearts all my
wonderful creatives here that that story
was meant to be told in a minute in 19
and when that distribution's changed and
it has i mean what's going to be left of
commercials
are you kidding me with ott
so this could be to inspire you
figure this world out because it's
actually the liberator of your happiness
and creativity
all right sorry i have to get this in
because you referenced certain times
monica ruski vp marketing budweiser for
those who don't know
gary creativity overrated
or underrated mom thanks for watching
that show by the way
for everybody's watching if you go to my
instagram garyvee please check this out
back to what i believe in i started it
randomly i had an idea i my algorithm on
instagram matters a lot i care
but i'm like no no creativity is
underrated
i'm going to be creative i'm going to
start the show overrated underrated and
now it's the most important thing i'm
doing on my
on my i mean nobody would think a four
minute igtv would outperform all these
best practice but it's the content baby
creativity is underrated it is
absolutely the variable of success
what is overrated is how we get to the
creative
in the ad and corporate world and when i
say overrated
it's obnoxious and that is what we need
to
fight for and the people that are
holding it up don't realize
that they'll do even better in the
opening up of it because they're
inherently talented and creative
all right gary thank you that was
amazing uh
you're a great partner your team do
amazing work for us we really appreciate
you joining us today
thank you bye everybody hit me up on
linkedin or on twitter garyvee and give
me some
feedback or insights i i'm really taking
advantage of covet and connecting with
people on linkedin
if i could be a help to any of you even
even the competitors you need some
talent i got
a bunch of people that want to try new
things so karma karma karma forever love
you
thank you so much youtube what's up it's
garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon